e
[Music]
good morning it being 11:00 thereabouts
we'll call the fiscal committee meeting
to order for February
21st and first item on the agenda is the
30th motion by uh Senator GR second by
Senator birdell to accept the minutes is
there any further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no minutes
are adopted there is no old
business and there is a consent calendar
covering tabs three and four there are
12 ite or no there are not 12 items on
it uh under Tab four
2540 was removed by the Department of
Education and the Reser request for
discussion on
25057 under Tab 4 Department of
Transportation the rest of the uh
consent calendar is at your disposal is
there a motion I'll move the consent
calendar motion by uh Senator gray
second by Senator Waters to accept the
rest of the consent calendar is any
further discussion seeing none all in
favor say I I oppose no consent calendar
is adopted uh Mr to shair just a comment
on
2557 is that part of that is it that I
want to talk about so although
transportation is involved uh they may
also want to be sitting at the table
when we talk director gou is present I'm
sure he's ready to answer any questions
I just didn't want him to make it to the
door
before Department of Transportation is
is uh requested a presence here for
answers to FIS
4 good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record my name's
David rodrig assistant commissioner and
chief engineer for the Department of
Transportation
welcome Senator gray my question is
about the 2.5
million because we're going out we're
buying a system
we're buying other things and that's
like you know
750 million or
750,000 but then I've got this 2 million
plus uh that look like I'm hiring
Consultants to do it normally I would
see that I'm going to save money uh by
buying a computer system that's going to
do
XYZ but then when I see this High
Personnel cost I don't understand it I
want to understand it yes and uh I'm I'm
going to give you both the opportunity
to talk well well thank you so much for
that question any the opportunity to
explain it what what does Grant is all
about and what this project is all about
is not one computer system the the do
from the time we plan a a project design
a project advertise it for construction
construct the project and then take all
the information from that project into
our systems to maintain and operate the
our infrastructure and assets through
the long-term life we have many many
many different systems some are paper
some are electronic and so forth so a
few examples surveyors go out with
surveying in instruments and get
information into a computer database
that database then feeds a different
design system what we use today is
called an open road system that's a
Bentley product that's what we use to
design on that information then goes to
the contractors who have computer
automated instruments on their equipment
that helps them to build the project we
then create as buils and then we take
that information for things like pipes
guard rail and others into an asset
management system so what we have is
many different systems some some work
well together today some don't work so
well together today what this project
does is lets us look at all those
different systems establish standards
data standards so we can start to get
these systems to work together and
coordinate together to be more efficient
and more
effective follow up well the line item
that the two .
405 million dollar is in is Consultants
yes and so is it a consultant for you
guys is a consultant for it what am I
saving because I'm spending $2 million
on Consultants how much am I saving to
get so that it makes sense to spend that
that 2.4 million right so the only way
we can do this work today with our
current resources and our current
knowledge
is with Consultants there is a huge
amount of work and expertise to look at
this these disperate systems and work
with those vendors to establish a
standards that lets us um con collect
and maintain the data consistently
throughout the entire process it's
really a lot of leg work and a lot of
documentation of our standards that
we're set setting up to to help us be
more efficient and effective in the long
run run this is all part of what we call
building information modeling or
building Information Management it's
been used in vertical construction for
many years Transportation or horizontal
construction has been using it for the
last 20 or so Years and we're getting
better at it New Hampshire is in the
middle to make maybe a little bit behind
the pack for the rest of the Dos across
the country this grant will help us
catch up and set up our systems to help
us be most effective for the next 10 or
more years it'll take us 10 or more
years to get to the end of this the
other thing this standardization does is
helps us very much with with our
attrition and helps us work through as
we lose people and bring new people on
it makes sure we have a very well
documented system that's easy for
everybody to follow so the majority of
this work is consultant driven it's in
documenting standards and putting
processes in place to help us be more
effective so is this a one-time cost and
I'm not going to see it in your budget
when you come before me in a couple of
months or is this an ongoing cost for
consultants and again go back back to
what I asked before is what's this going
to save me if not going to save me I'm
wondering why I'm doing it so so what
it's I'll take the the question of what
it's going to save you first what it's
going to save you is making our systems
more efficient so our Survey System
speaks better to our design system that
then speaks better to the contractor
system that they use to control their
their equipment their automation that
all works off of satellites and and GIS
so forth and then helps us collect that
information or use that information into
the future as we maintain that asset so
we know for instance what piece of
guardrail is where and what type of of
guardrail it is right now we have to
collect that as as a separate effort
once we have this system in place
there's no additional collection
everything flows through the system
automatically so that's the the savings
it also when not we don't do that uh the
best these days for Asset Management so
this will help us improve our asset
management capabilities and reduce our
overall life cycle cost of our assets
the reason we need Consultants to do it
one is because they have the expertise
we've Chosen and we're in the process of
finalizing a selection of a contractor
that or a consultant that has National
expertise with this and the other reason
is we don't have the people in house to
to do it when we work with a consultant
on a project like this I like to say we
want them to teach us to fish not give
us a fish so to answer your question are
you are we going to do this same thing
again and and bring it before your
committee no we are not but overall this
is an evolution so we're taking the
first five or six very big steps with
this with this consultant we will
continue to refine our systems and make
them better in the future follow
up we still haven't hit the thing how
much I'm going to save okay
um certainly outside of this meeting I'm
going to ask you for where I'm going to
save them where I'm going to see those
line items reduced in the budget that
comes to me from the house um so again
right now what I'm going to spend $3
million 700 almost $800,000 on the
equipment and stuff and then 2.4 million
on the people where's the savings and
how much right and and I don't have that
in a per dollar item I don't expect that
you're going to save that in the budget
that we're going to bring forward to you
I do expect in the long term the the
state is going to save considerably by
The increased efficiency that that this
brings I'd be happy for you to to or I'd
be happy to share some information about
this system with you
offline so we can get in more details
when when they talk about the the
Savings in this they talk about
efficiencies of 10% here and
15% here and I'd rather have some of
that documentation to to share with you
specifically oh return on investment Is
Not A New Concept and no when you come
in and spend $3 million and and 2.4 that
is on Consultants it makes me wonder
what the return on the dollar is so I've
got to vote on this today yes okay which
makes it difficult for me so I I hear
you and I'm sorry to to put you in the
position of having to trust me that th
this helps us to make our operations
significantly more more efficient and
that's what I'm asking you to
do representative F and then Senator k
no I oh you're all set all right Senator
Carson for a question thank you Mr
chairman good morning um I have uh two
questions is this project AI a high
priority for you for the Department for
for me personally this project is a a
higher priority a high priority this is
where we need to go today our CAD
specialist bill Caswell has 40 years
with the Department he has been involved
in our CAD System since it started in
1987 he is a leader in New Hampshire and
uh around he he's with us for a very
very short time this project documents
everything that that bill knows our
current practice and takes us forward to
where we need to be in the evolution of
how we design our our roadways so it is
a very high priority this is a Federal
grant this is a we will not have this
opportunity that I know of in the future
with State funds or with federal funds
that we are putting towards our
construction projects that's that's what
we do in here to Senator Gray's point we
want to give you a return on on our
investment so we try to put all our
money right towards the maintenance
operations and reconstruction of the
road this is an opportunity to move
ahead from a process perspective and a
technological
perspective follow up thank you Mr
chairman what is the timeline on this
when do you expect to start and when is
this project going to be finished we
expect to start this year and it's a 3
to four year duration so may I follow up
so in speaking to Senator Grave's point
we're not going to see any real return
from this until four years
out we every there there will be steps
along the way that we will see benefits
and improvements as we document our
standards better along this this new
process makes our communication with
private surveyors with engineering
consultants and with contractors better
and better all the time so we'll see
some some step in improvements thank you
thank you Mr chairman any other member
of the committee Senator
rosenal thank you Mr chairman was this a
competitive Grant this was a competitive
Grant thank you so when you tell us
efficiency that either means the project
will be done quicker or fewer people
will be required and that's that's what
we're expecting to see perhaps not
immediately but hopefully long term
you'll be able to
definitely say this is as a result of
the system and I am confident we will
deliver those two two things and the
third thing that that the these systems
provide for us is an overall lower life
cycle cost of our assets as we keep
better track of them and as we manage
them best best for the longest
serviceable life thank you f
um just so everybody knows where I am
okay this is this is federal
dollars I am going to make a motion at
the end of this uh you know for
acceptance uh but I will be wanting
additional information when you present
your budget before the Senate uh that
tells me how I'm saving you know money
because I'm spending this money and with
that I will move the Autumn to approve
it who was a second Senator Rose okay
Senator gray moves to accept item 2557
and Senator Ros all seconds is there any
further discussion on the item seeing
none all those in favor say I I oppose
no the item is adopted and commissioner
goule I'm sorry that that you didn't get
but okay moving on to tab five on the
and that's item
25054 that's the uh Department of Health
and Human Services any questions on the
item Senator
Rosenwald thank you see finance officer
gray white will come forward I got the
minute thank you Mr chairman good
morning
Nathan
um I think I understand why there was
extra money in the Managed Care lines
but I'm wondering if you could tell us
why there's a $16 million shortfall in
the children's health insurance program
is it more
kids that didn't fall off the program or
is it sicker kids or a
combination that just seems like a
really big amount sure uh Nathan white
chief officer of the Department of
Health and Human Services I'm going to
have Henry Litman talk about some of the
trends that we've seen um I do want to
point out though that in the past for
the last state fiscal year we also had
to make a similar transfer uh in this it
in this area to the chip
program so historically the then the
children's health insurance program and
for the record by the way Henry Litman
State Medicaid director um we um did not
separately have a line item for
children's health insurance program it
was mixed into the Medicaid managed care
we started to um budget it separately so
we could track it better um then the
pandemic kicked in and enrollment with
continuous enrollment affected the
because that happened after we budgeted
for it and so we've been between that
and now that there's continuous coverage
the federal requirement that started
January 1 of 24 to cover kids for 12
months continuously the assumptions that
we had you know in beginning to break
out that component um we're sort of
chasing that I think as we prepare the
26 27 budget we now have the experience
and understanding to budget that better
but the the dollars if you will had that
we budgeted in the entirety of the medic
Managed Care Program were adequate to
cover it's just Distributing it between
the lines that's what's going on here
and we'll have a better accurate
distribution as we go forward
follow up thank you but aren't children
all fee for service no um children are
nearly all are children that are in the
health insurance component they're
covered by managed care as
um when we see your
budget um
are we going to
see a a truer
more I mean you're going to account for
this $32
million yes I think we won't have the
the um the public health emergency
Distortion of three and three and a half
years of continuous enrollment we won't
have the new federal policy coming in
all those things affected the accuracy
of our our budgeting um and but in the
aggregate we got it very
close thank
you further from the committee
members the item Senator gray moves
approval Senator bird sell seconds to
adopt FIS
25054 is there any further
discussion seeing none all in favor say
I I oppose no the item is adopted moving
on to tab
six looking at the
25047 fees for the par
Mr
chairman representative Lehman will have
a
question introduce yourself
please good morning everyone uh jorth
general manager at Kon Mountain Frank
con State Park thank you for coming
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question so in the letter that
we received on January 31st roughly it
talks about a slight adjustment and a
moderate rate increase in offseason and
and uh cost and I was a little puzzled
maybe I've been looking at numbers too
long in the last couple of days but uh
looking at your tier one and tier two
and early bird uh the pop of the second
page I'm not quite following that I see
that the winter 2425 is 799 and then it
says early bird 799 off season 899 and
then over to in season 999 is that the
increase to 999
for offseason or inseason purchase or
it's a little bit more complicated than
that um first of all on the menu that
you're looking at you're looking at two
sets of prices for two different seasons
first of all um under the tab winter
2024 25 and then with columns in tier
one and tier 2 those are the prices for
this current season's uh winter season
passes and you can see the date ranges
at which those um past prices are in
effect and that's what essentially we
mean by tier um The Proposal on this uh
next winter seasons passes is under the
tab winter 2025 2026 there's just some
nomenclature change to the to the tiers
um you know first of all what I'm
calling early bird is essentially the
same as tier one um and it'd be
important to note that as part of The
Proposal um I'm I'm proposing a price
freeze when we go out to market for now
next season's winter passes I want to
keep all passes at exactly the same
price um secondly the offseason tier is
uh it's expanded somewhat um I would
seek to initiate that price on May 1st
and run it all the way through um
November 28th um of of next year which
is when our anticipated opening date
will be and then I think importantly is
um I I have advocated and proposed to
this committee that creation and
delineation of a third tier for us
called
inseason um inseason passes are
presently sold at Canon Mountain for
sure and they essentially occupy what is
presently our tier 2 rates um but I view
it as critical and also consistent with
uh the industry to create an inseason
tier um and a subsequent price increase
there uh this is done pretty commonly at
a at a host of other mountains including
in the state um most notably Gunstock
ragged um some of our a mountain that is
very similar to Canon uh J peak in
Vermont operates very similarly and the
idea behind this um sir is that uh you
know as much as we can do to drive
Advanced commitment um this is a tried
andrue strategy to offer guests um and
passholders the opportunity to purchase
earlier at a discounted rate and uh
encourage um folks prior to the season
beginning to jump on the program so that
would be a change pretty much as you
look at the 2025 2026 um prices you'll
see that early bird tier where when we
would go on sale again those prices are
Frozen um secondly as we go to the off
season tier um the majority of those
prices are I propose um to go up by 1.8%
there's one tier in there the uh u29
Group which I propose to go up 3.8
% um but otherwise it's 1.8% across the
board and no changes to military or
special use passes like our uphill
passes on any tier and then thirdly is
on that inseason tier with its creation
this would be valid um there's there's
two important notes for Canon only
passes these are for folks who are not
New Hampshire residents that would go
into effect on November 28th when um we
anticipate being open and then for new
residents um that inseason tier would
take effect um after the RSA deadline so
um as prescribed
[Music]
in um RSA 227 colon 14 reduce rates um
there's the prescription for me as the
mountain manager to offer discounted
rates on season passes through December
14th to New Hampshire residence that's
commonly done um same thing here uh but
our inseason for New Hampshire resident
passes would then uh begin uh December
15th that is also consistent with what
we do presently um I just wanted to make
sure it was is clear and and for you all
to consider I hope that answered your
up I guess I'm concerned if I'm the
resident here in New Hampshire and I log
on to your site that I can say well gee
if I buy my ticket now it's going to
cost this much if I buy my ticket next
season for The Following Season how much
it's going to be it just seems it's it's
not as clear but maybe it's just me but
um I think uh for some additional
context one thing that I see in terms of
uh our pass unit sales the vast majority
of our pass unit sales for Canon only
passes these are mostly out of state
visitors um those occur during um the
spring and summer um that's when the
vast majority of those are sold pretty
much the same with New Hampshire
resident passes although we do see a
number of New Hampshire residents
there's a larger percentage of them that
buy later in the season and particularly
in season so I I couldn't explain
exactly why that is to you other than
the fact that our New Hampshire
residents tend to like buying season
passes
later okay well thanks thank you Mr
chairman further from the committee how
much have your operating costs gone up
year-over year
uh well uh you know anywhere between 5
and 11% um we were aided by a
renegotiation of a favor well an
unfavorable utility contract we were uh
able to get a new rate coming into this
year so some of the impacts to Canon's
budget which had affected the place um
pretty unfavorably in the last two years
have been corrected um with some further
cost control and some contemporary
financial management practices um you
know we've sought to certainly control
but we certainly see the impact of uh
inflation um wage compression there were
a number of wage increases that were
authorized um at the park service and
then at Canam Mountain within the last
couple of years so it's important for us
to uh maintain our level of uh of
self-sufficiency um in our rates while
also maintaining our position as a value
leader in the
market how's your snow been um this is
uh this is probably the best the
mountain has looked in several years um
we have uh 99% of the mountain open um
we're above median in terms of natural
snowfall we've had uh huge success with
snowmaking this year um the conditions
have been uh really remarkable uh
visitation been up revenues are up um
costs are down um slightly and I think
it's all really positive I think most
notably I also wanted to share with the
committee we uh we conduct um post visit
surveys with all guests where we just we
try to Benchmark ourselves against the
industry and a host of uh metrics um
National Skies Association releases a
report called the key report where
they look at industry benchmarks and in
particular um they they asked the
question and and we can pay ourselves
against the question of what is the
value for price paid of the products we
asked that specific question of all of
our product holders from day tickets um
beginner tickets pass holders Etc Canon
is in a very strong position as it
relates to value for price paid right
now we uh Trend at about an average of
8.3 um out of 10 versus a regional
Northeast industry average of eight so
folks who especially
passholders um highly utilize the
mountain um they view it as a good value
and um we're trending above our industry
peers
you're very thorough thank you move the
item Senor great moves adoption of the
item I think it was Senator birdell
seconds further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no 25 047 is
adopted thank you thank you moving on to
tab
seven item 25
048 Department of Corrections is there
any questions on this
item second representative Lehman moves
to adopt the item Senator gray
seconds Senator Waters has a question
HKS thank you for the record Helen Hanks
commissioner of the Department of
Corrections
Senator thank you commissioner
um you know I know the struggle over
many years on Staffing and so forth and
um I wanted to get a s a couple sense of
a couple things for you um H how do you
see the trends in Your Capacity to hire
the staff you need and then secondly I
noticed you've got 116 eligible for
retirement and I you know it went the
retirements went up a little bit when Co
started and they're down a little bit
and so on but um what do you anticipate
in terms of that fairly large group um
and what pressure that's going to put on
you to have successful
recruitment thank you for that question
Senator the
117 uh at the time of this report which
was uh 123 2025 in fresh numbers this
morning we have 107 who are in that
retirement eligible uh category 60 of
them are sworn law enforcement and of
the 107 36 of them have 25 plus years or
more of service I think it's a very um
hard prediction uh to figure out uh how
many may or may not choose to retire I
think it's very also clear as the topic
of group two retirement uh occurs if the
retirement system is adjusted again more
favorably we will see an uptick in the
number of people who choose to retire
and deservedly so given the hours
they've put forward to the state of New
Hampshire um but the promising number is
watching our Trends in Recruitment and
we continue to recruit and work to
retain all of our staff across all of
the professionals it takes to run the
Department of Corrections and just in
the numbers we've hired uh three more
since I uh sent the data so we're up to
a total of 33 just in our law
enforcement ranks and we have 32 or
excuse me 34 in the cube so we're just
being much more aggressive and assertive
um recruiting for the same uh entry
level individuals that all law
enforcement does across the state of New
Hampshire I may follow up follow so I
mean this much what we're doing today is
about the overtime and fairly not not
not unexpected um but is do you have any
sense about the relationship between the
um you know what we're going to see
trending on that overtime number uh
based on what you see trending as your
capacity to fill full-time positions
Senator if our capacity to continue to
recruit which is what I've always
advocated for happens we are going to
stay steady and continue to um mitigate
anybody body's deserved retirement or
departure from the agency I I did send
out to house finance and others and I
think it's important to note that the
number of overtime hours is actually
decreased so as we've recruited
individuals and our population has
declined so we've shut down and kept one
whole floor shut down in one of our
larger general population housing units
that means there's 14 posts that we
don't fill every day of the year I think
another important piece we don't talk
enough about is we've reduced our
reincarceration rate we literally have
reduced the number of people by 8% in 7
years who come back to incarceration
that represents just roughly under 20000
people who have not come back to
incarceration if you look at the daily
incarceration rate which is
$252 a day that's approximately $90,000
of the Department of Corrections has
saved the state in just individuals not
returning to incarceration you do that
multiplication that's somewhere around
$14 million so it's really the totality
of everything we're doing in the
department both in recruitment treatment
and programming and being truly the
Department of Corrections and as long as
we're funded and continue that effort
we're headed in the right direction on
behalf of the State of New Hampshire
thank you thank you chairman
congratulations thank you
sir anything further from the
committee is there a motion to adopt the
item did that we did that all
right any further discussion seeing none
all in favor say I I oppose no the item
is adopted thank you very much for your
progress okay we're moving on to
informational items is there any
particular item anybody wishes to remove
to be discussed Mr chair Senator bsel
just have a question um I have to leave
at noon and I was wondering if we could
um go over the um human
rights um before I leave the the audit
yep yeah and and if there so you want to
start that now obviously there's nobody
has any requests for the information
Audits and the request has been that the
first one be the uh commission for human
rights
good morning good
morning for the record I'm Christine
Young director of AUD aits for the
LBA and uh we are going to present our
performance audit of the New Hampshire
commission for human rights John clinch
from our office was the InCharge manager
on this audit he'll present the report
and uh joining us are Katrina Taylor she
is the acting assistant director of the
commission and also Sean Lock he is a
senior Assistant Attorney General from
the Department of Justice
they were instrumental in uh helping us
to close this audit um and finalize the
report and uh they're here to represent
the commission on behalf of a key
employee who was out on leave um during
the audit and uh with that I'll turn it
presentation good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is John
clinch and I'm a senior audit manager
with the office of legislative budget
assistant I'm here to present our
performance audit on the New Hampshire
commission for human rights I'd like to
provide you with an overview of the
report and then I'd be happy to open uh
it up for questions and comments at the
end as shown on the transmitt letter on
Roman Nal I our objective was to
determine whether the commission
efficiently and effectively enforced
laws against discrimination when
receiving investigating and making
findings on complaints
our audit period was State fiscal years
2020 through
2023 please turn to our executive
summary on page one which describes the
results of our
audit we found the commission was
inefficient and ineffective in
investigating complaints and closing
cases in a timely manner we also found
the commission had not established a
method to measure its Effectiveness such
as tracking how long it took to process
cases Effectiveness was negatively
impacted by EXP spired administrative
rules lengthy investigations and
inadequate
training tools for managing extensions
and other delays from parties appearing
before the commission had also not been
established we found the commission had
long-standing issues that had not been
adequately addressed case backlogs from
as early as 1984 continue through the
present day the legislature took steps
to address the backlog in state fiscal
year 2024 by adding four investigator
positions and two administrative
positions but filling these positions
has been slow due to continued staff
turnover case backlogs were worsened by
the assignment of investigators to
non-investing tasks when administrative
positions were unfilled or
unfunded we found a lack of basic
management controls such as establishing
a strategic plan identifying objectives
developing per performance measures and
identifying and responding to
operational
risks we also found policies and
procedures for investigators and
Commissioners were deficient the manuals
used to communicate policies and
procedures were disorganized contain
typographical errors and referenced
outdated statutes court rulings and
expired
rules the commission did not have
reliable program data on which to base
its operational
decisions case data were maintained
manually in several spreadsheets and
publicly reported data were
inaccurate finally we found several
findings from our 2019 Financial audit
report remained
unresolved for example the commission's
administrative rules had expired in
2015 this was cited as a deficiency in
our 2019 Financial audit yet the
commission's rules remain unexpired to
this
day by banial reports had not been filed
during the audit period additionally
statements of financial interest
required by Statute had not been filed
by some Commissioners or had not been
complet completed
correctly our recommendation summary
begins on page three and contains 20 25
observations with
recommendations the commission fully
concurred with 24 observations and
concurred in part with one observation
two recommendations numbers 10 and 13
may require legislative
action turning to page
seven our background section discusses
the types of discrimination cases
commission page
11 shows an illustration of the
commission's case process as you can see
there are numerous steps in the process
contributing to the time it takes to
process a
case figure two on page
13 shows most pending cases are
employment
cases and table one on page 14 notes the
commission's revenues and expenditures
for the audit
period I'd like to take a minute to
discuss observation number one on page
due to its significance to the
commission and our audit
objectives this observation discusses
the average length of time the
commission took to process
cases figure three on page
18 shows case processing time through
various stages of the commission's
process it's important to note not every
case follows the same path some cases
are withdrawn after filing or they could
go through the entire process uh and
have a public hearing cases can also be
delayed if the parties to the case
request more time the commission could
administratively close a case under some
circumstances such as the death of a
complainant while the case is in is with
the
commission all these factors should be
taken into consideration when I discuss
average time
frames figure three shows it took an
average of 840 days or 2.3 years between
case filing and case
closure our Figures were calculated
based on 228 cases with data sufficient
for
analysis figure three also shows the
time from case filing to investigator
assignment for a subset of cases
averaged 557 days or 1 and A2
years following investigator assignment
a case could take two different paths
one of which is to proceed to a probable
cause determination which on average
took 398 days after the investigator was
assigned if a case was closed after
investigator assignment but before
probable cause determination the case
took an average of 384 days following
investigator assignment
no cases went to public hearing during
State fiscal year
2023 we found 62 cases or approximately
27% of the cases we reviewed took so
long to close that the complaintants
could no longer remove the case to
Superior Court within three-year statute
of limitations
deadline we recommended the commission
ensure cases are processed timely by
tracking dates of important case events
for such for each case develop
administrative rules to establish
deadlines for amendments and extensions
and evaluate the costs and benefits of
different methods of tracking cases
system that was a very high level
overview of our findings I mentioned
earlier that the report includes 25
findings with
recommendations uh for improving
management controls investigations and
compliance corrective actions will take
time to implement especially while the
commission continues to conduct
investigations and has uh position
that remain
unfilled the the appendices are found in
tab sections of the report and include
our scope objective and methodology in
tab a the commission's response to our
audit in tab B results from our survey
of attorneys that had worked with
parties of the Commission in tab C and
the current status of Prior audit
observations in tab
D before I conclude my prepared remarks
I'd like to thank commission staff and
Commissioners and the attorney from the
Department of Justice further assistance
during this audit uh with a chair's
permission I'd like to turn it over to
comments hi good morning everyone my
name is Katrina Taylor I am the acting
assistant director uh unfortunately our
executive director could not be here
today so I am here um and I just really
wanted to first of all thank the LBA for
their recommendations uh we do
appreciate that the audit acknowledges
that Staffing and managing the really
heavy demands placed upon the commission
have been decades long this is not a
recent phenomenon by any means um we
really look forward to implementing
these
recommendations um to provide more
transparency and
efficiency um I do believe um I know I'm
a temporary acting assistant director
but I am very confident um that with
these recommendations and the additional
resources that we were allocated over
this past budget cycle um that we are
going to be able to better manage um the
existing backlog and go forward um so I
really again wanted to thank Mr clinch
and his office for their cooperation
their
recommendations um and thank you all for
being here Senator
gray uh certainly if note in appendix
D um there's one two three four five six
six 7 8
[Music]
n findings that go all the way back to
2019 um and then there's two that are
predate that by over 10 years and so
what is the commitment to resolve those
issues get your rules issued
Etc yeah so unfortunately I was not in a
position of man this is again I've
acting assistant director it's very
temporary very recent um so I cannot
attest to that in my position is where
I'm at right now with the Commissioners
I know that we are all committed to
moving forward um our priority right now
especially is those administrative rules
and that's from my perspective I don't
know Sean wanted to add
anything I would agree with that that's
been a priority for the past um several
years there was a person there was a
staff person tasked with updating and
revising the rules they Departed the
commission um as that process was going
forward but we are working the
commission's working with OS and jail
and getting ready for rules to be
presented to jail car um to put rules in
place and then there'll be follow-up
amendments as kind of noted in the
commission's responses to address some
of the recommendations from the audit as
well followup I will want someone to
contact my office on a a good answer to
this question so please have that happen
absolutely Senator birdell did you have
questions okay Senator Lehman and then
Senator Waters a representative Lehman
and then Senator Waters thanks for the
promotion Mr chairman
um so I don't know where to begin I feel
sympathetic to the acting director but I
read one of the comments from one of the
attorneys back in section what C5 that
it's been going on for 20 years that the
service has been terrible I I think he
used the word terrible or she doesn't
um and I guess it begs the question
because this has been a historic problem
uh and your agency is asking for at
least $3 million in general funds in
this coming session does it make sense
to continue because again things need to
move forward uh it takes times for rules
you've got a backlog I think was like
259 cases I'm I'm just concerned that
the request has been made for addition
additional funding yet apparently this
issue uh of cases being handled in a
timely manner and number of other things
that the audit folks found has been long
term I just curious of your response or
maybe a a better question for the
gentleman from the Attorney General's
office so I can speak again briefly um I
can't speak for what has happened in the
past I have been an employee there for
11 and a half years but I've never been
in management um um when I started our
backlog was about 175 cases so again
this is a long-existing issue I have no
information right now in regards to the
budget I was not the one who put that
together um so I am going to be working
with the doj in their business office um
to answer those questions better in the
next week or so I would just add here to
that is you know one working with our
business office because the agency is
administratively attached to the
department um but also you know some of
this you know shortly after before
Katrina had started with the commission
the agency had had this would go back to
about 2012 its Staffing cut by a third
and it remained in that status despite
requesting additional resources for
almost a decade it wasn't until about
2020 that they received additional
resources and during that time that's
when we see addition with staff turnover
if you have Three Investigators and one
investigator leaves you've lost a third
of your capacity to M to manage the
cases that are coming in the cases that
have been coming in haven't decreased
over time I've looked at legislative
histories in different context going
back to the 9s where comments were made
you know about Staffing at the
Commission in the backlog cases that
hostile work environment claims
disability discrimination claims these
are new laws and they'd be temporary
blips in the increase of cases the
commission would receive that hasn't
borne out over time they've remained
significant sources of cases coming into
the commission so it's it's an impact
that is kind of cascaded from some
requests the commit the efforts the
commission has made to get its Staffing
built up so it can manage the case load
in front of it that's happened recently
and so that's why the commission is
optimistic that with these rules and
these amendments and some of these
proposals and recommendations were
collaborations between the LBA Auditors
and the commission and recommending time
limits firm time limits that can be
incorporated into the rules limitations
on amendments to cases because we looked
through the commission
cases that had been pending for an
extended period of time and found you
know there'd be a case that was ready to
go to a probable cause or no probable
cause determination and the complainant
would amend the charge to add a
retaliation claim that charge now has to
be investigated one of the
recommendations would be that there's a
limit on when that can occur when an
amendment can be made as a matter of
right or when a person would have to
file a new charge of discrimination
instead of amending and starting the
process over which extends the time that
it takes for a case to process other
examples of issues that have Arisen that
have kind of caused some cases to
languish longer than others parties
asking for additional time it's a
recurring issue it was a recurring issue
where I'm going on vacation I'm going to
be out of the office I need an
additional month to do something two
months to do something those add up over
time and that leads to again or
attorney's Changing Hands the the
business that's
being investigated is you know their
attorney leaves they get a new attorney
I need six months to get up to speed on
this it leads to those increases in time
so it's not necessarily solely something
within the commission's control it's
also the parties appearing before but
rules and more transparent rules about
those processes would help facilitate
and kind of prevent some of that maybe
for lack of at word abuse of kind of
their procedures that have existed in
the past further question Mr chairman
further thank you I guess I'm concerned
because I said as the division chair
that received the request last session
for additional help we were told that I
think if we had four more investigators
added that uh there'd be a tick down if
you will a number of cases uh we answer
the requests not many people received
additional staff in the last budget uh
we provided that and yet again the case
loads have gone up I understand maybe
you haven't been able to fill but it's
still very concerning to me and I'm sure
the rest of the members up here that
when people go V to the Human Rights
Commission it takes years to get a
response or a decision and we're just
not meeting the needs of the people of
our state and again my concern about
again the amount of money that's been
spent and we seem to be going backwards
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question Senator Waters and then
Senator
Carson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you all and and you know assistant
acting assistant director I appreciate
your situation um so I guess Mr chairman
what I would wonder is that um if we
could have some follow-up information
onto an exact a precise schedule for the
um preparation and submission to rules
to jail
car that that I think we need to know
it's rather vague in here we need I
think we need to know how you're going
to accomplish that um secondly I think
this will probably come out through
house finance but it would be good to
know how the money has been applied um
from the that increased from the last
budget just you know H what has resulted
and who is hired and how have the duties
been maybe been separated out as they
should be between the people working on
cases and the administrative tasks um
but thirdly uh Mr chairman I I think on
this one we we need to have a mechanism
here in this committee to follow up and
I don't know what schedule you'd want to
put whether it be you know once a month
or every couple months that they come in
we have to work through this um because
it I I do not I'm not con I'm not
confident there's the capacity for the
commission to um implement the
recommendations and if and I I think
that's why we're just going to have to
monitor because this situation can't
continue thank you Mr
chairman Senator Carson thank you excuse
me thank you Mr chairman uh my question
is for turnning lock um in going through
these it seems like part of the problem
are is the large number of prosay
litigants they they're really ignorant
of the legal process and they don't
understand everything that's going
through and I think back to what the
legislature did a few years ago by
allowing paral legals to work under the
direction of an attorney to work with
prosade litigant in Family Court do you
think that that is something that would
help this process going
forward I think representation could
help in those capacities um would still
come down to are those people able to
even find paralal services to assist
them but um it could help because it
helps it would help with kind of keeping
the cases more organized I think some of
the challenges with self-represented
individuals is that tracking them down
being in contact with them getting the
records you need and I think uh
Katrina's even better poised to answer
that question speak to that than I am um
it it does create significant challenges
um and and it can again lead to delays
because there might not be the the rapid
response some people are in difficult
situations if they've lost employment
they're looking for new employment
they're not as concerned with responding
to a request from the commission so and
I'll let uh Kina speak to that even more
okay yeah um I think and again it's
really for me it goes down to the volume
of complaints um we get at least 25
complaints per month um and so the
consistence volume I don't for me I'm
not sure I do think it would help those
folks absolutely um but for me I don't
know if it would decrease the number of
filings that we see um every
year thank
you further questions from the committee
Senator
gray um the recommendation was made that
there may be um need for legislative
action on 10 and
13 I would like some more information
about
what you believe that legislative action
could be
uh the Senate has a lot more leeway in
adding things to bills that they
have uh so picking a senator to uh at
least have that discussion with whether
it's me or someone
else uh would be to to me it may help
along I can speak from a statutory
standpoint looking at recommendation 10
um what it boils down to is some
additional language that could be added
to the statute to make it very clear
that um the Commissioners can rely on
staff to facilitate the conciliation
process so it's pretty straightforward I
think recommendation 13 you'll see in
why it's a concurrent part is that the
commission doesn't necessarily agree
that statutory changes are necessary
although the LBA
does well we can't attempt to do it
until you get either myself or one of
the other Senators that language okay
and it should be on 10 and it should be
on 13 and if we have a bill that
is close or deals with that same statute
or whether we hold a public hearing you
know we might be able to help you if you
come see us thank you Senator
gr uh I value very much the audits that
come from the audit division and where
they since we are the first legislative
group to see them when they suggest
that legislative fixes are involved I
will file that legislation we have the
opportunity to put it in hb2 but I need
to get the suggestion within three weeks
sure thank you so much we' also be
anxious to learn by the next meeting
your progress on the uh the adoption of
your rules sure so we'd like to see
those either by next meeting or the one
succeeding if you're not finished by
then but I always take the uh
appreciation of the of the work done by
audit division and I always file the
legislation when I see any that's needed
so we need to get that input from you
unfortunately we have a an opportunity
to put it in hb2 so sure we'll look
forward to getting those
soon further from the committee uh
representative walner I just wanted to
uh make a statement that the house
Judiciary Committee should probably be
involved
in um in looking at this audit and
monitoring it we will make sure that
you representative
Griffin thank you I ju I just uh I'm
really concerned that a uh person who
petitions the board is going to be
really depressed about the amount of
time at takes to react to the
petition and uh it seems to me that the
old adage that Justice delayed is
Justice denied really comes into play
when the time
period uh from the initial filing to the
case being determined and
closed is as long as it is and it's got
to be discouraging
to a uh petitioner who goes there I know
from my own experience I've had
constituents call me up and complain
about the time period and U somehow
we've got to figure out how to shorten
that period because
otherwise the whole existence of the
further from the committee so our new
procedure says that we have at the time
that these are released the LBA releases
it so the normal motion is to accept the
report place it on file and release in
the usual manner that has already been
done
so that that has been accomplished so
you've been instructed as to what we
expect to get back uh pretty soon from
this audit and appreciate the
thoroughness of the audit division as
usual anything else on this audit we
okay they always do that put them in you
can do it if you got more thorough way
to do it that's
fine I always fall love because nobody
else
welcome so the next uh audits are the
annual reports of the college savings
plans and as you know our office retains
the services of price Waterhouse Coopers
for these Audits and uh with us is um
Sean K he's the partner with PWC and
Monica mespelli our state treasurer and
the trustee of the plans is also
available for questions and comments and
with that I'll turn it over to Sean
super thank you thank you very much
appreciate the chance to be here this
afternoon and share with you the results
of the audits that our firm conducted
what's in in scope is the unique College
investing plan and the Fidelity advisor
529 plan both are uh under um annual
examination as of September 30th um I
have advi U by the way sorry my name is
Sean K and I am a partner with price
waterhous Coopers been with the firm for
26 years um but this is my first year
presenting on behalf of our firm we have
three documents in front of us which one
will you start with uh frankly the uh
the one that you have in your hand there
is just fine um those materials are for
your reference there's one page that
I'll speak to in a moment and that'll
comments so as I said the the fiscal
year end of these structures are
September 30th um in November of
2024 uh we presented the state of New
Hampshire and the treasurer's office
with our audit results and those audit
results have been positive and then on
December 12th and December 19th I issued
clean unqualified opinions on the
results of both of those structures so
if I could direct your attention to page
five that'll be a good page that we can
from the title of that page is the
status of our
Audits and I just wanted to focus on our
discuss today so I did Issue unqualified
opinions uh meaning clean opinions on
the results uh for each of the
structures and those were issued on
again December 12th and December
December
19th my team did not identify any
controll deficiencies that Rose to the
level of material weakness or
significant deficiency so not just good
audit results but also good impacts and
good uh assessments on internal controls
uh we received the full cooperation of
all the service providers um that we
came into contact with that includes the
individuals at Fidelity and also the
folks at the State of New
Hampshire um similarily uh my team
achieved every objective that we had set
forth in our plan we had no restrictions
on where we wanted to go on what we
needed to see as it related to um some
very specific audit objectives we um
independently confirmed the existence of
100% of the assets we
uh repriced independently without error
or uh without issue 100% of the items
that were in for valuation and as it
relates to the p&l items income into the
funds and expenses that went out of the
funds uh we observed no material
differences in any of our audit results
so very very clean audit results uh as
as is customary with these
structures finally I'll just highlight
as it relates to the state of New
Hampshire fees that go to the State of
New Hampshire um those uh those um
results that I shared with you extend to
the fees that are received by the state
of New Hampshire we had no differences
no audit differences noted in our
independent recalculation of those fees
okay so the remainder report is again
for your reference unfortunately it's
called required Communications and so
it's very similar to what we've
presented to you in the past but it it
highlights and reaffirms for the group
that uh our firm is is independent of
the structures we identified no fraud
all of the related party transactions
that are required to be disclosed have
been disclosed um and that um and that
there were no disagreements with
managements and again no issues errors
unadjusted items or audit adjustments
that were
identified at this time I'm happy to
answer any questions that anyone has on
those audit
results questions from the
committee happy to say that some of us
in present uh with the um guidance of
our Madam Treasurer we look at all these
accounts quarterly so we have a lot of
familiarity with these and uh I know
she's keeping track of every dollar as
she always does so there any other
questions from the committee so the
motion has been made that the report be
accepted placed on file and released in
the usual Manner and that will be done
if there's no other
questions then and I guess the next
thing is to pick a date thank you very
much for your good work welcome to New
kindly
so we'll discuss the usual third Friday
third Friday would bring to um the 21st
of
March so let's take a look at our
schedules and see if anybody has any
restriction or
any
um
request for any particular starting time
I have
a senator gray I have a university
system Board of Trustees meeting
that uh usually it gets out around noon
time
so I wouldn't be available until the
afternoon but that
I'm not the only one any other conflicts
with anybody on most of us aren't
scheduled that far ahead Senator Carson
I um I have the children's oversight
Commission in the morning which usually
can go between 10 and between 9 and 11
and then in the afternoon I have the um
New Hampshire Ireland trade council at
1:30 so up your day doesn't it yeah oh
that's okay um so if I mean 11:00 worked
well for me um because this doesn't seem
I mean I know it can run long but
um you think it might be able to be
present for most of it if we had it at
11: yeah I think so chairman
Representatives any preference one way
or the other all right let's schedule it
Mr Kane yes so we're talking Friday the
21st 11:00 for fiscal if we have a pre
fiscal we'll probably do it at at 10:00
for the members of the house
okay all right
11:00 Friday the 21st for the next
month's fiscal yes
welcome representative Smith I know you
wanted to hear this audit and I think
both you and I would be impressed from
what we've seen in the quarterly
the while you and I have are involved in
the issues that the treasurer just
presented and I'm always pleased to see
how well that's going I what brought me
here today of course is the very very
longstanding and serious problem of the
Human Rights Commission and I will tell
you that the house Judiciary Committee
uh starting in uh
2021 has been involved in this problem
and finally in
2022 went to the Joint performance audit
committee to ask for the
um to ask for the performance audit
knowing the incredibly fine work that
the LBA always does and knowing what a
difficult conundrum this was going to
present I think they've done their usual
incredibly fine job um where they do
just the facts ma'am and um I will also
tell you that while the chair of the
house Judiciary Committee has been at
out of the country for a few weeks he
and I have been in uh uh touch about
this issue and he is planning to
schedule um a meeting to which the uh
Human Rights Commission um and the LBA
will be invited for them to make a
presentation and to talk about what we
can do and of course even under existing
house rules although Senator gray is
right that the Senate has so much more
flexibility a committee can uh with good
reason uh without regard to the ordinary
time schedule um come forward with
legislation so between House Bill two
and what the house Judiciary Committee
might do we might be able to try to see
if we can solve a problem that's
essential because while the easiest
thing for us to all do is throw up our
hands and say let's just get rid of the
the Human Rights Commission that does
not do justice to the citizens of the
state who should be able to depend upon
um a more responsible
reliable uh commission we have the
federal EOC at least at the moment who
might be able to do some employment
stuff but that's not the only problem
and I am very appreciative of the fact
that the fiscal committee has moved this
along and thank you very much well I'm
going to see to it that Mr Kaine gives
you enough copies to present to the
Judiciary Committee and give them your
impression of of the audit delivery well
thank you of course I know that Mr Kain
will do absolutely everything that needs
to be done to make this work because he
always has Senator Waters thanks you Mr
chairman just a comment um I'm I really
appreciate the house Judiciary Committee
taking this on I think we heard another
suggestion from Senator Carson about an
area because it does seem to me just
aside from 10 and 13 in the audit I read
through and I see a lot of other things
that may require legislative uh uh
attention and I I'm sure you'll be very
thorough on it but um I think there's
much more here that needs to be looked
at from a legislative perspective than
just 10 and 13 so I just wanted to
mention that Mr chairman thank you the
senator if I could comment on that CER
where you're absolutely right um there
are
there have been procedures which have
been
followed which I hope this is not too
strong a word which have been
unconscionable um and show a a lack of
respect for the institutions of the
state including not only the rsas but
the rules and um that should not be
allowed to go on and this uh performance
audit has cre created an opportunity for
us to do the right thing thank you
anything further from the committee okay
I guess we all got a 1:00 so we will